think it tells the world that christian
bee hasn't gone away
as the suspect in the madeleine mccann
case
he's been formally made a suspect as far
as the portuguese authorities
are now concerned
as if he didn't know that he was under
suspicion
it's a little complicated but the german
authorities are the lead investigators
in this investigation
along with the portuguese and with
scotland yard but the portuguese and
scotland yard are playing very minor
roles
so the germans have been pursuing
christian bee
for what i'm told is perhaps as much as
long as four years
they believe that madeleine is dead they
believe that christian bee
was responsible
and her death
they say they have a good circumstantial
case against him
but they have yet to charge him and i
think what's happened in portugal is
that under portuguese law there's a
statute of limitations which rules out
prosecution in serious cases like kidnap
and murder
15 years on after a crime is thought to
have been committed now that clock stops
running in the case of the madeline
mccann investigation
on the third of may uh this year which
is the 15th anniversary of her
disappearance and i think this is
perhaps an insurance policy by the
portuguese authorities that if the
germans decide at the end of the day
not to charge christian b and release
him from the madeleine investigation
then the portuguese can pick up the
baton and pursue a prosecution
themselves